I don't know if it's just me
but I feel like this is the time of the year
where most of us get burnt out
because hear me out
but it's been so long since Christmas break
and yet we've still got all of the busy months to get through
so I'm calling it Self Care September
and honestly it's been so long since I've had
a facial or any kind of pampering
so I decided to treat myself to a luxurious
Red Door spa service with Elizabeth Arden at Farmers
and I might have been living under a rock
but I had no idea that you could get an Elizabeth Arden facial
at selected Farmers stores
they do an express for 15 minutes or you can do
a 60 or 90 minute facial
and the cost of the booking is redeemable on products
which I think is great
my amazing aesthetician Jobyda
decided I would benefit most from a Lift and Firm Ceramide Facial
we started off with a double cleanse and an exfoliation
before giving me a lifting facial
massage with the Advanced Ceramide Capsules
we did a face mask which was just so satisfying to peel off
and then she used their unique Skintervention tool
which I've never seen before
but honestly I want one
it used light and heat to reduce the
appearance of fine lines and wrinkles
leaving you with firmer and smoother skin
I walked out of there feeling so relaxed and at this time of the year
and for me at this time of the month
I really needed that
Jobyda show me what she used on me during my treatment
and also recommended a couple of things
that I should be using at home
and one of them was these Advanced Ceramide Capsules
which I've been using at home
for over a year now
and these are precise premeasured
biodegradable capsules with
high potency targeted actives
and they feel absolutely beautiful on the skin